all right folks this is beyond parody we
now have pictures of trump's toilet
with the flushed documents
it's beyond belief
you might remember
that during his presidency donald trump
was obsessed with toilets the only
president i can remember
this fixated on what we call the third
element of the bathroom remember this
viral moment with trump and toilets we
have a
situation where we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers right
and other elements of bathrooms
where
you turn the faucet on in areas where
there's tremendous amounts of water
where the water rushes out to sea
because you could never handle it
and you don't get any water you turn on
the faucet you don't get any water
they
take a shower and water comes dripping
out it's dripping out very
quietly
quietly what quiet water that's not that
you're not getting the water pressure
you need there now
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once
yeah and and when this this was so
bizarre
and then we learned that donald trump
would regularly flush documents down the
toilet in direct contravention to the
presidential records act he would just
flush him and then i realized this is
why trump was so concerned with the
third element of the bathroom well trump
denied that he was doing that and now we
have the pictures exclusive this is the
first time on this program i have ever
brought to you pictures of a toilet
but here are pictures
uh
that axios was able to obtain and you
see a piece of paper in the toilet
uh it says rogers it says stefanik elise
stefanik is a republican congresswoman
we have it and axios reports remember
our toilet scoop earlier this year
maggie haberman's forthcoming book about
trump will report that the white house
staff periodically found wads of paper
clogging a toilet and believe trump was
the flusher
it turns out there are photos published
for the first time habermann obtained
the photos recently shared them with
axios ahead of their the release of her
book a trump white house source tells
her the photo on the left shows a
commode in the white house the photo on
the right is from an overseas trip folks
trump was using foreign plumbing to
dispose of these massive dumps of notes
this is an unbelievable situation it is
2022
and we now have toilet pictures proving
that donald trump was indeed flushing
notes down the toilet maybe explaining
why he was so displeased with the
suction level
of
the toilets
at the white house
i i don't know guy i think i might have
to retire i genuinely don't what is the
point of me continuing to do the show
after a story like this
um but this is where we are and as usual
the narrative continues to be
story comes out trump denies it then
there are pictures then there's a phone
call then there's proof that goes above
and beyond
i i don't even
i feel it only
diminishes the story
if i say more
it sort of needs to be a presented
without further comment type of thing so
i will leave it there
if you want to see
the proof
make sure you're following us on
instagram
at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is xebiotix a
probiotic drink that breaks down the
byproduct of alcohol which is most
responsible for some of those rough
mornings if you drink a small bottle of
zebiotics before your first drink of
alcohol
and then drink responsibly guys please
get a good night's sleep you can enjoy
the next day feeling refreshed and ready
to make the most of it sam cedar
swears by it here's how it works
when you drink a toxic byproduct of
alcohol builds up
in your unprepared gut
this byproduct causes you to feel
terrible the day after drinking
zebiotics produces an enzyme like the
one your liver uses to break down the
byproduct and zebiotics is fda compliant
for safety this is a product for
responsible adults who have just a few
drinks
but they have plans tomorrow they want
to feel their best we all want to feel
our best if zebiotics doesn't work for
you you get your money back guys it's
that simple
go to zbiotics.com
pacman and use the code pacman for 15
off your first order the link is down
below